let's crush that hunger
[Music]
i'm a happy girl
[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharp your no bs
registered dietitian today we're going
to do a little vlog and i'm going to
teach you all about the hunger crushing
combo
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor squarespace so if you're not
familiar with squarespace it's an
all-in-one platform to run your business
whether you're looking to build a
website blog online store or use their
marketing tools and analytics so as a
busy dietitian and blogger myself i love
that squarespace has features that allow
you to schedule appointments through an
online calendar and set up email
campaigns for a mailing list it's also
so easy to seamlessly pull content
directly from instagram or twitter when
everything in your digital presence
works together like this it just makes
it so much easier for you to focus on
your actual business so you can check
out squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
slash squarespace.com sharp to save 10
off of your first purchase of a website
or domain
but first i'm going to throw out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with past or previous
experiences with disordered eating
and of course a reminder to subscribe to
this channel if you are new here
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on an episode so as a
jumping off point for today's hunger
crushing combos i asked you on my
youtube community page
what was your or is your trigger food or
your kind of fear food in other words
what is the food that you feel like you
can't control yourself around or maybe
when you were struggling with disordered
eating in the past what was the food
that really made you feel anxious and i
want to take that food and make it not
scary anymore i want to show you how you
can incorporate that for your food into
a balanced snack or meal
any day of the week not on a cheat day
so we're gonna do a hunger crushing
combo every day for a full week i am
really excited about this i hope that
i'm gonna get some new ideas for snacks
and meals just based around some of your
preliminary suggestions so on that note
let's do it
so we're gonna start with my personal
trigger food from back in the day
sugary cereal
if sugary cereal was in the house i
would just kind of eat it by the handful
and so for me it took allowing myself a
bowl of cereal every single day for the
novelty to just like totally wear off
so i'm going to show you how to
hunger crush combo
this cereal
what's this guy named tony
i'm coming for you
let's do this okay so you maybe saw me
do this in my wedding a day video but
basically i take some protein powder
and i mix that in
with a little milk of your choice
that is going to boost up the protein
like so much doesn't matter what cereal
you use you know you're going to get
some protein in there to help
bump up the satiety factor then we got
the good stuff
[Music]
it's sweet but
i love it got some strawberries that's
our fiber
handful of cashews
for
some healthy fats
check it out
[Music]
so to recap we've got protein from the
protein powder we have some healthy fats
with some fiber and a little bit of
protein in the cashews and we got more
fiber in the berries she is crushing it
and also
so delicious
the crunch factor is out of control if
my husband was here
he would leave he would be so mad
i'm not mad
[Music]
all right i'm coming at you with the
liquid calories now i
totally understand those of you who
called out any kind of formal liquid
calories as
your arch nemesis and your fear of food
i know when i was struggling with
disorder eating like the thought of
drinking 200 calories worth of i don't
know mainly sugar
was terrifying to me but the reality is
that we can turn this into a hunger
crushing combo
and you can do it straight from the box
what
it's like a slang for starbucks they're
all over the place i ordered this on my
app it is that easy to turn this into a
balanced snack so let's do it
[Music]
here we got those little sous-vide egg
bites which are strangely addictive like
they got the weirdest spongy
kind of squishy texture and i am i'm
digging them so we got our protein
straight up delicious protein we got the
avocado spread which is going to be our
healthy fats and our fiber
love avocado this goes on everything
like a little guacamole packet of
goodness and then
we got our coffee and in fact i get
mine with the soy milk um so we're also
getting a little bit of protein in here
too
and it's sweeter than i remember really
sweet i'm not sure i'm gonna be able to
finish it but
i'm gonna give it a valiant effort so
i'm gonna
smear a little
his little avocado hat
house we need
she's good
[Music]
another big fear food that i heard from
a lot of you guys is oil
so i'm gonna show you that you can
combine it with lots of protein and
veggies and you're gonna have a really
super balanced hunger crushing combo so
let's crush it
okay so today we've got some cauliflower
some tempeh and some sweet potatoes and
we're gonna do a little quick meal prep
here and add a little bit of oil just so
that they get nice and golden brown and
honestly a little bit of oil goes a
really long way
[Music]
my
[Music]
all right so take a little peek see at
this we've got our protein in the tempeh
we've got lots of fiber in our sweet
potatoes and our beautiful cauliflower
and we've got that little bit of oil so
we've got those healthy fats and i also
added in some more fats for flavor so i
added some tamponade and some pesto but
this looks like an awesome meal crushing
that hunger
let's get in there
i don't even know where to start
too much going on
[Music]
she's good
and i gotta tell you
having just that little teeny bit of oil
makes a world of a difference to getting
that beautiful caramelization and just
the texture and the flavor so i just
feel like a little bit can go a really
long way at totally amplifying the
flavor and the texture of a good
balanced meal
nothing to be afraid of
[Music]
all right folks today we are going to do
the bagel yes a ton of you guys
requested bagels suggesting that you
know bagels or bread uh were really your
trigger or fear foods and yes i know i
say bagel weird don't troll me just how
i say it don't nobody understand the
words that are coming out of your mouth
man but i can totally appreciate and
understand the sentiment because i feel
like when i was struggling with my
relationship with food
bagels were scary like
this
terrifying bagel with cream cheese
oh no so yeah now looking back i'm like
i feel so bad this is just a real piece
of bread with a hole in the middle so
we're gonna turn
this
beautiful thing that we know and love as
the bagel into a delicious balanced
hunger crushing combo sandwich so let's
do it
all right so we've got some chickpeas
here just rinsed drained from the can
because i'm too lazy to cook my own
pop those in
got some
avocado and this is a beaut look at that
look at that beauty
in
where
where
give everybody a mash oh my goodness
it's gonna get messy
a little squirt
lemon juice
salt and peppy
we need a little seasoning here
adding in
everything but the bagel spice
yep lots of that
yes yes yes yes yes
load up our bagel here
where where
got some
gorgeous tomatoes
a little lettuce action
this first cucks
keeps going down
oh no
this is gonna be messy ah
okay maybe just one two slice
this is gonna have to be
snack on the side
stay
let's dive in
[Music]
all right let's talk about this beauty
so we've got our protein in the
chickpeas plus a little bit of fiber as
well we've got fiber and healthy fats in
the avocado more fiber in the veggies
plus of course the bread itself also has
a little bit of fiber and a little bit
of protein so we cannot discount that
and we've got the flavor of everything
bagel on a bagel
whoa that is that is meta
right that is meta i should have gotten
on everything bagel bagel what was i
thinking i was thinking this was gonna
be delicious so let's do this
[Music]
cheap
cheerful
delicious and balanced that my friends
is how you do
a bagel
[Music]
all right folks another day another
hunger crushing combo
today we're digging into these bad boys
cookies specifically oreos which i feel
like are a class of food
all on their own i admitly am not a
cookie person but
i'll eat these
and
judging by the state of this package we
have been eating them
actually uh mainly my husband of course
but i've definitely gotten in on the
action myself so today we are going to
take these to the next level and i'm
gonna make my famous protein ice cream
with these it's gonna be amazing let's
do it
so to my blender i've got a cup of
frozen bananas
two-thirds of a cup here of cottage
cheese
got a tablespoon of
peanut butter
and we'll do two delicious oreos
saved
[Music]
so i cannot wait to dive into this but
of course it's so beautiful outside i
had to have the nice cream outside in
this beautiful summer weather now having
said that i've basically let it melt out
here while i've set up the camera but
still it's going to be delicious but
let's break down the hunger crushing
combo protein from our cottage cheese
we've got a little bit of fiber in our
bananas plus more fiber and some healthy
fats in that nut butter and we've got
the deliciousness of our oreos so
can't go wrong right cannot go wrong
let me taste this
come on
i'm actually like floored
how much
those two little oreos flavor like that
whole big batch of
like my protein nice cream
like i'm amazed my kid e
is going to love this he's going to be
obsessed
um yeah this is a keeper
[Music]
this morning we're having ice cream
and my fellow canadians if you know you
know i guess that's really my ontario
wins
uh because this is like an ontario brand
and i grew up in the kwarthas
so
it is the best this is my hubby's
favorite death by chocolate
um i'm not really a chocolate person but
i figure it is probably like the most
popular ice cream flavor so we're gonna
do the hunger crushing combo for
chocolate and if this was your kind of
trigger food um you're gonna see that it
is definitely not sling to be feared
i'm eating it for breakfast literally
okay so
we have
some beautiful frozen dark cherries that
i just thought out
[Music]
and there's like cherry juice on the
bottom that i just gotta get
it's good
chocolate and cherry classic combination
and we're also going to mix in some
almonds in there so we've got
some fiber here that's our fiber of
course and also lots of antioxidants
i'm gonna get
some
ice cream
this is like gonna be like a sunday
it's so much better because i'm eating
it for breakfast
so like a half a cup i don't know
a little more it's good
this one's for me
should have brought paper towels
some nice droopy
almond butter so this is going to be our
healthy fats plus some protein plus some
fibers we really are representing across
the board here
and then the nuts
check this out
[Music]
hunger crushing combo and she's gonna
satisfy you know that we've got our
fiber in our cherries we've got fiber
protein and healthy fats in our almonds
and our almond butter and we've got some
chocolate ice cream for good measure
so let's get in there
i gotta get a little chocolate chip
chunk
it's actually better with all the
accoutrements in there
because you get that that's a perfect
pairing cherries almonds
chocolate
i'm a happy girl
[Music]
all right lovelies we're gonna talk
about another popular trigger food
chocolate and not
like the dark antioxidant rich who bars
or whatever hue bars hu whatever the
ones that all the influencers eat
no no we're talking like
milk chocolate that you would pick up
when you are grocery shopping and you're
at the checkout line and it's just like
sitting there and you're like that one
i just want the basic dairy milk bar
this is what i actually like i don't
like fancy chocolate i just like
the basics um so this is definitely what
i would like to eat so we're gonna turn
this into a super balanced hunger
crushing combo and i'm really excited
about it because i'm hungry so
let's do this we are gonna make my
famous protest today which is my protein
oats you've seen me make them on um
vlogs before they are a staple on my
website abby's kitchen because they are
so popular for reason they are
absolutely
dreamy they taste like eating a cloud
but this is going to be a chocolate
cloud so i don't think it gets better
than that
a little bit of oats
water
let's let that cook a little salt
cinnamon
let that cook
and frost up some egg whites
now i'm going to add in some super ripe
frozen banana
let that cook down into a mush
then we're going to take our beaten egg
whites
nice and frothy
put them
into
the oats
whip that together
just like this
keep them nice and frothy
make sure that cooks through
and no this does not taste like egg
whites
and when i turn off the heat
pop a lid on
let it sit a few moments later time
to
serve
so fluffy so dreamy oh my goodness
and a huge huge bowl here so i've got
some
beautiful strawberries
one little color we've got some pecans
here any nuts also would work
and
our milk chocolate
hello friend
let that melt oh my goodness
i'm excited for this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we have nailed this we have
some fiber rich carbs in the berries and
of course the oats
we've got some healthy fats in the nuts
and you can use it whatever nut you want
we've got some protein in the egg whites
obviously
and we have a whole lot of deliciousness
i mean
wow
what is not to love about this it's a
chocolate cloud it is literally a
chocolate cloud and i am like
salivating i can't even talk
that's how i'm excited about this i am
guys
this is insane
oh my god why have i not done this
before this has changed my whole life
yeah
i'm happy
[Music]
well folks i hope that gave you some
great inspiration for some balanced
meals and snacks if you like this video
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below on other vlogs and
ideas for videos that you want to see me
do here subscribe to the channel and
i'll see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
you